foreign
what's up man
where are you coming from
where do you stay
stop right now
[Music]
you better stop right now
all right Delta 1600 I lost them near
the uh clubhouse
blue flannel like sweatpants a blue
sweater glasses short black hair
white male probably 120 pounds okay uh
about five eight
you can see a little spot back there
let's announce itself now
or you'll be bit
Sheriff's Office
is pretty heavy
there's a helmet or something right
there see it a person laying down get up
get up now
let's shoot get up now show me your
fucking hands right now get out
let's go
put James behind your back
[Music]
be secured because you know what you did
we know what you did that's why we're
here
I thought there's a canine here but a
helicopter was here I thought it's about
what you say 15 or 20 deputies that were
here
there's reason for that
why is that
okay
yes that's why that's weird man it makes
people uneasy and puts people you know
like it puts a weird feeling in your gut
when you find out someone's looking at
you through a window
there you're look like this outside of a
window peeking through it and the
neighbor says Hey and you're like oh
you take off don't ringing a bell in
your head
okay what would you do if some man was
peeping at your at your wife through a
window
you know you wouldn't go whooping right
you know
all right all right I got your phone
we'll get you some warmth and uh I don't
know we have any dry clothes
right here
don't don't go reaching anything just go
right on the hood stands right on the
hood
what was the problem what I'm saying
what's the problem you're gonna you know
what turn up no no no no I don't want a
problem I want your hands on the hood
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
okay where you at now I can come have a
conversation with you make sure you're
okay
why not all I need to do is check your
well-being and make sure that you're
okay
so if he's not leaving a spot he was he
was in the woods he walked through his
car to charge his phone but he's
unwilling to meet because he doesn't
want to be Baker active because he feels
that uh going being put away like that
is going to just cause call the kangaroo
having to lock up the store please
he's walking out towards the cars he's
right by the dumpster
do you want us to challenge him
that has to be your decision there just
you use caution he's he's probably got
that single zero on him
for criminal charges on this guys just
to pay correct
[Music]
this is Joel
can you hear me
I can uh I can hear you
so I'm just gonna go ahead and talk I'm
here
at the uh the gas station
I'm with the Sheriff's Office and I'm
here to
to try to talk to you and uh
what I can do for you to uh
I understand you've been talking to some
other people for a while
I'm right here so
I uh nobody's been hurt you're not hurt
nobody out here is hurt you're not in
any trouble
Let's uh let's try to work through this
together
and um
and just come up with a resolution to
this that works for you and and for us
here
we've we've we've already we've already
talked about that I I agree with you I
don't I don't know the situation you're
in and I won't pretend to know the
situation here and but man to man
the one thing that you have that that
makes you have to continue on to the
next day are those two lives that you uh
you brought you brought this world
no matter how bad it is for you you owe
it to them
a lot of reasons
a lot of reasons that uh you're not done
a lot of reasons why you
a lot of things to continue on for so
that gone away and
come out here and
let us get the help that uh
that you need
[Music]
I think you want this to
be over peacefully I think you
oh I know you're I know you're
you're in every word that you say
I also hear you tell me over and over
again that you want to save yourself
I want to help you do that
[Music]
over here
take a deep breath
your fighting is only making it worse
calm down
you're not going anywhere the game's
over all right no it's not it is
it is you're done okay
stop fighting it's only gonna get worse
if you keep fighting we're gonna keep
fighting huh
huh you're not gonna keep fighting
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers let me see your hands do not move
do not move I'm a dog like you
no no no no no no no no
stop put your hand behind your back hand
around your back and I'll take them off
of you stop hands behind you stop let go
of my dog please make him stop let go
with him stop let go stop I can't my
fingers in the car they're leave
stop
stop please it's in the least stop stop
please let go of it please I can't yes
you can I can't it's in the leash
let go it's in the leash please
dude please let go look at that one it's
the other one hey hold on what's the
other one please I can see it please put
your head where I can take care I don't
want to get a bitch you got the gun get
down now
stop
the gun drop the gun
drop the gun
stop
me dude
get your dog off of me
drop the gun man
drop the gun
off of me
foreign
[Applause]
stop biting me
[Music]
let's go
gotcha gotcha
we go
please let me go
stomach turn over on your stomach let go
of the dog
let go of the dog
stop biting these earrings
put get on your stomach no stop
me up help
all right lay down on your stomach lay
down on your stomach lay down on your
stomach right here on this side down by
the hip right here right here please
please please
and Italian is another thing there
weren't all flat clothing one had long
drives and one had a top knot on their
heads I'm at Hamilton and New York the
SUV's directly behind me I'm gonna hold
them up right here
I'm right behind you right now
whoa
our suspects in the back of it guys he's
in the back of it dreadhead
[Music]
12f
what you doing southbound Hamilton
they're known suspects I can't tell if
he's got a gun pointed at me or not
right there
[Music]
wc1
looks like he had a gun point at me at
the back window
[Music]
air one you got them
Dead four coming up to Lawton right now
and we are eastbound on lot from
Hamilton
[Applause]
right now Pursuits authorized don't go
over 80 miles an hour
I need an answer did he point it on you
had a gun yeah
stick it
[Music]
still Northbound still Northbound on 17.
coming up to Minnesota
[Music]
right there it is right there
still northbound
get up to Orange Camp through the light
around the car
patch
10-3 bailout bailout at the CBS running
towards Starbucks
through the parking lot black male all
black dreads
you're gonna get shot you're gonna get
shot
[Music]
don't move
where's the other one
we got one of them
[Music]
24 we got one custody
14 he just flipped me off to the window
increasing speeds at 75 14 31 or even go
ahead and get yourself takes out
foreign
[Music]
show me ahead
[Applause]
where are you gonna go where are you
gonna go put the bat down
put the bat down
put it down
[Music]
you're gonna get tased get your hands up
he's got a knife
Armand go Leslie
stop stop
Put The Knife Down check the knife Put
The Knife Down art and go less lethal
Put The Knife down now
you are gonna get tased or shot put it
down
you're gonna get dog bit bro
foreign
[Applause]
yeah
okay I got the machete I got the knife
okay
um we got things we got the machete we
got the knife we just tracked up to his
hat his machete and his baseball bat
[Applause]
show me your hands show me your hands
come down
guys
do it now
let me see your right hand come on dude
come on down
did I guys come on down let's go come on
down
6194 we're 10 12 boys I mean he's not
showing us this thing it's definitive
tree
all right well go ahead and hoist
yourself up on your arms
hoist yourself up buddy
all right all right get the feeling back
in your legs and come on down I'm good
with that
he's going he's going
northbound
just turned left heading back to the uh
Loi head back to the house in the
cul-de-sac
behind the house at the two corner
behind the acid and two Corner got one
male X big driver's side door running to
the north behind the houses
foreign
Drive looks like a bunch of Apartments
towards Ridgeview Drive
okay head to your left head to your left
head towards the woods right there
go straight in where your right arm is
now
10 feet in from where you're in he's
laying down in the bush not moving could
probably give commands and he might come
out you might be able to hear you
okay
not that we can see
still just underneath the tree line
yeah it looks like he's trying to crawl
away from you guys further into the
woods
all right
he's moving to your left now that's to
the north
he's heading towards uh
129 Pine Valley Court
129 Pine Valley he's actually in that
backyard right now
show me your hands let me light him up
where are you man speak up we're in
contact
me
I'm out of here
yeah right here
what are you doing man
hands up well I ain't dragging you out
you're way too fucking big for me
roll it around your belly
all right
shut up no man all right do you want the
German Shepherd to pull you out then
fail
I'm making no fucking effort to get out
oh
on your stomach
did you really
y'all see me in a week
I know it
tell hey put that put that on your body
cam
yeah spread your feet
spread your feet